cioè non sopporto le saux presenza e non
sognavo questo la piccola ruby non è il
ragazzo ci sogniamo cioè era piccolo
sono gli ab soldi le barche una ditta
comunque già da e sta facendo il culo
saper fare un certo livello di vita non
mi vanno sicuramente incassare in una
situazione per un ragazzo già non ha
niente non all azienda come le mie
amiche mi chiedo tutti i compagni con le
aziende
invece lui va un lavoro normalissimo va
bene quello che volevo io e la figura
della polla e stacco di spoglio il
ragazzo ai viola figure di neppure il
pazzo e perfino c'è dolo né non esteri
abbiamo quella cosa con me stessa il
timore della povertà che spiego di bollo
voglio fare ruben
come ti senti bene ma non benissimo
sono un po deluso perché comunque
bisogna portare un po di rispetto per
una persona che è stata punta da due
anni e io adesso esco di qua e sarò
ancora più uomo di lei e neanche esco
con lei
francesco scusami risparmi la crema
sulle spalle anche se no mi il cotto per
favore io ne voglio trovare un altro ma
nessuno li calcola di quelli che
viaggiano mai quei soldi l'unico stronzo
che mi taglio agli uomini maghetti
pensili ti faccio venire a tempo the
show nalin per farti calato storiella al
phylum all uomo per una volta che a noi
poi prendi battere filippo di una idea
non è nemmeno idea nella cattivera che
sta usando nei confronti dei commi sta
trattando devo essere sincero filippo io
questa cosa che l'ha presa in braccio mi
ha dato molto fastidio non l'ho mai
vista interagire con nessuno
nessun altro ragazzo ma lo sarà non fumo
rimette a fumare una sigaretta ma che
schifo parla una sigaretta tra fumi con
un altro fa schifo proprio a meglio
morire delle star come perché mente
umana di roma e quando mi guarda negli
occhi mi dice la cosa io ci credo ma che
senza usate e del virgilio legalisti che
ho visto mi va di fare ma che cazzo dice
a testa
mi stai fa del male utilizzate la somma
cia bacia il naso e la sofia e questo le
ragazze mutai c'è stato eletto non sta
ne in cielo ne in cielo ne in terra